Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
As machine learning research advances over
time, learning-based techniques are getting
better and better at generating images, or
even creating videos when given a topic.
A few episodes ago, we talked about a DeepMind’s
Dual Video Discriminator technique, in which,
multiple neural networks compete against each
other, teaching our machines to synthesize
a collection of 2-second long videos.
One of the key advantages of this method was
that it also learned the concept of changes
in the camera view, zooming in on an object,
and understood that if someone draws something
with a pen, the ink has to remain on the paper
unchanged.
However, generally, if we wish to ask an AI
to synthesize assets for us, in many cases,
we’ll likely have an exact idea of what
we are looking for.
In these cases, we are looking for a little
more artistic control than this technique
offers us.
So, can we get around this?
If so, how?
Well, we can!
I’ll tell you how in a moment, but to understand
this solution, we first have to have a firm
grasp on the concept of latent spaces.
You can think of a latent space as a compressed
representation that tries to capture the essence
of the dataset that we have at hand.
You can see a similar latent space method
in action here that captures the key features
that set different kinds of fonts apart and
presents these options on a 2D plane, and
here, you see our technique that builds a
latent space for modeling a wide range of
photorealistic material models that we can
explore.
And now to this new work.
What this tries to do is find a path in the
latent space of these images that relates
to intuitive concepts like camera zooming,
rotation or shifting.
That’s not an easy task, but if we can pull
it off, we’ll have more artistic control
over these generated images, which would be
immensely useful for many creative tasks.
This new work can perform that, and not only
that, but it is also able to learn the concept
of color enhancement, and can even increase
or decrease the contrast of these images.
The key idea of this paper is that this can
be done through trying to find crazy, non-linear
trajectories in these latent spaces that happen
to relate to these intuitive concepts.
It is not perfect in a sense that we can indeed
zoom in on the picture of this dog, but the
posture of the dog also changes, and it even
seems like we’re starting out with a puppy
that grows up frame by frame.
This means that we have learned to navigate
this latent space, but there is still some
additional fat in these movements, which is
a typical side effect of latent space-based
techniques and also, don’t forget that the
training data the AI is given also has its
own limits.
However, as you see, we are now one step closer
to not only having an AI that synthesizes
images for us, but one that does it exactly
with the camera setup, rotation, and colors
that we are looking for.
What a time to be alive!
If you wish to see beautiful formulations
of walks…walks in latent spaces, that is,
make sure to have a look at the paper in the
video description.
Also, note that we have now appeared on instagram
with bite-sized pieces of our bite-sized videos.
Yes, it is quite peculiar.
Make sure to check it out, just search for
two minute papers on instagram or click the
link in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!